[Musica]
esprimi il tuo malessere se un po
patetico dettare legge come fossi un
politico col tuo computer su internet
mettiti comodo con tanti idioti come the
internet ology lo fai dai tempi dei
fancazzisti anonimi l'educazione demodè
insulti facili commenti inutili
allora insulta
d
pensi di farmi male
ac
che cosa fare non
vince
[Musica]
a risultare
casa
[Musica]
italia
finita
[Musica]
medaglia
ma vige mi fa salire i crimini manco a
lei
elementari usavo insulti simili
siamo tutti i giudici sul web e quindi
siediti e dopo sfogati allora in testa
mattina
così michael
[Musica]
digitali
risultato
ecc island
mediaset
in italia
[Musica]
finita
ogni tanto per cambiare un po diamo dei
cancri aimale sogni terzini italia
[Musica]
sogni testini italia
la mia sia
a fratel che
[Musica]
soglie
sì vita
[Musica]
finita
[Applauso]